the morning mist clears only slowly over
the patent basin in nasarah bow Maya the
Maya forest
the ruins of the ancient Mayan city of
Tikal tower above the treetops like
skyscrapers the temples are evidence of
an advanced civilization in the middle
of the rainforest Tikal has been
interpreted as meaning place of the
voices nowadays the Bark's of howler
monkeys dominate the forest it's unclear
what caused the downfall of the Maya
about a thousand years ago there are
many theories disease Wars climate
change they have a culture for almost
two thousand years there's a lot of
people many people obviously they live
to some extent in in harmony and I think
that is something we can learn from the
past yep sure is a biologist whose aim
is to bring the rainforest into harmony
with people today together with local
conservation organizations he's
developing sustainable concepts for
protecting the forest the bread nut tree
the Mayas used its seeds long ago here
the seeds are called Mayan nuts they're
harvested twice a year the people from
the forest village of gotcha tune go out
to collect the seeds the seeds had long
been forgotten but nowadays they're
being eaten and traded again
then Bhaskar para me significant
embraces the forest means an income from
me if the harvest is good our family
alone can deliver up to 90 kilos a day
which means almost 50 euros a day for us
for Donna Magdalena and her family of 11
the Maya nuts are an important source of
income the village has a permit the
villagers can use the forest with
certain restrictions but sustainable
management is an exception in Guatemala
not far away the rain forest has already
disappeared seventy percent of it has
been deforested in just 20 years
now it's grazing and farmland more and
more people need food the trouble is
that the soil is very poor anyone who
wants to raise cattle needs large tracts
of land another disaster for the forest
is drug smuggling what happens is that
the people that do the drug smuggling
they have a lot of money it's black
money and they want to whitewash the
money and what they do is they buy large
tracts of land which has all been
illegally DeForest it and then transfer
it into cattle but the forest is gone
wants to force this gun it's very bit
difficult to bring the forest back yup
Shaw and his colleague Victor Ramos from
the National Council for protected areas
have been monitoring the extent of
deforestation in the region for years
with the support of the international
climate change initiative they record
the disappearance of the rainforest this
is the forest in 2000 what you see in
green dark green and light green is
forest and what you see in light yellow
is agriculture and cattle ranching at
2000 this is 2007 and this is 2013
3000 plant and nearly a thousand animal
species among the many birds live here
the Selva Maya is rich in biodiversity
many species are unique to it as the
rainforest disappears
they lose their habitat the guaca Maya
wants a symbol of the Mayan Sun God the
parrots in this breeding station are
meant to provide offspring
there are only an estimated 300 Birds
belonging to this type of macaw living
in the wild the greatest threat to these
macaws is loss of the habitat that comes
illegal trade the chicks are taken from
the nests and sold on the black market
at prices of up to $5,000 dollars until
the parents are large enough they remain
in the station then they released into
the wild
the mccall can live up to 80 years
whether the forest will exist that long
is doubtful back to the village of yucca
torn the seeds of the bread nut tree are
processed in this facility turned into
flour or ready-made biscuits the project
provides work for the women led by a
team from the German international
cooperation agency and forest expert
Julio Madrid not fascinates me because
it tastes delicious
and it's very healthy it contains many
important nutrients for example lots of
vitamins some of the products remain in
the region but since a few years ago
most have been exported mainly to the US
to date there are eight communities that
process and sell Maya nuts the proceeds
provide an increasing source of income
for the families
the forest also benefits because
experience shows that most of the areas
in the set of amyum in which people live
are in good shape the inhabitants feel
responsible for the trees and protect
them the areas that aren't inhabited
often provide easy pickings for loggers
without the people you cannot protect
the forest so you need people to protect
the forest and you need people to earn
money from the forest in one way or
another otherwise it's a lost cause
Guatemala means land of forests but only
when people's attitudes change in this
natural paradise be preserved
you